is a special gift to all the old people
out there
boy bejar's Valentine's Day off to a
rocky start I'm not saying that I'm
upset yeah The View host had a bit of a
wardrobe malfunction during Tuesday's
episode and her co-hosts specifically
Whoopi Goldberg completely lose it the
biggest surprise happened to us seconds
ago when Joy's bra started making all
kinds of eyes at people at the table it
all happened during commercial break and
when the ladies return Whoopi gives
insight into the moment I mean it was
like an earthquake and suddenly the bra
was like I left Happy Valley it was
something else she almost put my eye out
from where I was sitting despite the
mishap Joy makes light of the situation
another special gift to all the old
people out there
all the old guys they know what to
expect from me I'm me I'm me they know
Joy they have people know me and the fun
doesn't stop there
to Rivals as they attempt to contain
themselves before moving on Whoopi can't
resist a little jab at her colleague you
know a whole lot of people are
speculating about what's been hovering
it's her breasts over American Stars
Joy's been a panelist on the daytime
talker since 1997 but stepped away for
two years when she was temporarily fired
in 2013. I was summarily dismissed and
then I was They begged me to come back
and here I am since her return Joy's all
for having a good time at the table fun
more fun I want more fun as for Woods
brought her back money and uh also
geography I live right close by yeah Joy
is full of jokes even when it's b day
what's my special gift to all the old
people out there
all the old guys
[Music]